neuer ärger für flugreisende die kabinen
gewerkschaft ufo duft von montag bis
neuer zur streiks bei der lufthansa
tochter germanwings auf flugzeugunglück
in kasachstan eine passagiermaschine mit
fast 100 menschen an bord stürzt ab
mindestens zwölf kommen ums leben und
aus bei der darts wm nach ihrem
historischen siegeszug verfehlt die
25-jährige fällen das achtelfinale
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem freitag norbert nebenan ist auch
dabei für den spachtel dann doch von mir
wir beginnen mit einem zerrütteten
verhältnis seit monaten herrscht dicke
luft zwischen europas größtem
luftfahrtkonzern der lufthansa und der
vergleichsweise kleinen kabinen
gewerkschaft ufo ein schlichtungsversuch
am sonntag vor weihnachten hat offenbar
wenig gebracht jetzt will ufo wieder den
druck erhöhen
die lufthansa tochter germanwings wird
drei tage lang bestreikt und zwar von
montag 0 uhr bis einschließlich neuer
also mittwoch 24 uhr isabel de la vega
berichtet erneut will die gewerkschaft
ufo streiten und ganz klar benennt ihr
sprecher den grund es gehe um den
überlebenskampf einer
spartengewerkschaft hier steht eine
kleine schlagkräftige gewerkschaft die
gegen raubbau an den mitarbeiter
interessen kämpft ja und damit eben mit
allen mitteln dagegen gehalten es gibt
zahme gewerkschaften eine verdi wehrt
sich nicht derartig und da versucht der
konzern ist schon seit einiger zeit die
ufo loszuwerden und die verdi zu
ersetzen
der streik kommt dennoch überraschend
noch im november hatten lufthansa und
ufo eine schlichtung vereinbart dann
tauschte die lufthansa ihre
personalchefin bettina folkens aus
angeblich sei sie zu sehr auf die ufo
zugegangen
bei den folgenden gesprächen konnten
sich die parteien dann noch nicht einmal
mehr auf die inhalte einer schlichtung
einigen die lufthansa verfolgt einen
harten kurs doch auch die gewerkschaft
pokert hoch
im november waren bereits 200.000
passagiere vom arbeitskampf betroffen
nun könnten so ufo auf den streik bei
germanwings weitere
arbeitsniederlegungen bei den anderen
lufthansa töchtern ab januar folgen
die drohkulisse steht birgt aber das
risiko dass die kunden irgendwann auch
die streiks leid sind und womöglich dann
wirklich den schwarzen peter der
gewerkschaft zu schieben das heißt die
öffentliche meinung sich gegen die
gewerkschaft wendet das ist
ein ganz schmaler grat den ufo oder
gehen muss
der schmale grat heißt macht zu
demonstrieren ohne alles porzellan zu
zerschlagen
denn am ende findet sich eine lösung nur
am verhandlungstisch
peter wagner am frankfurter flughafen
welche passagiere sind denn jetzt von
diesem streik betroffen also von dem
streik sind nur passagiere der euro
wings betroffen und zwar nur dann wenn
auf ihrem ticket steht ihr flug sei
durch german wings durchgeführt also
operated by german wings das könnten an
diesen drei tagen etwa ein drittel aller
euro wings flüge seien
es empfiehlt sich also für jeden der bei
eur wings gebucht hat und zwischen
montag und mittwoch fliegen will
weil seine fluggesellschaft also bei
euro ging es nochmal genau nachzufragen
ob der eigene flug dann auch betroffen
ist jetzt bestreikt ufo nicht lufthansa
sondern eben mit germanwings eine
relativ kleine tochter der tochter was
ist das für ein signal
ja ich glaube schon das ist ein signal
der gewerkschaft in richtung lufthansa
die bilder mit sagen wir machen erstmal
so noch mal einen kleinen streik
eigentlich wollen wir ja verhandelt
eigentlich wollen wir eine schlichtung
wir wollen eine lösung und wenn das
wirklich so ist dann müsste jetzt glaube
ich lufthansa ihrerseits wieder ein
signal aussenden man müsste sagen wir
sind verhandlungsbereit und vor allem
eine neue vertrauensbasis schaffen denn
das vertrauen zwischen beiden seiten das
haben wir eben auch gehört dem beitrag
ist völlig zerstört und wenn es eine
lösung geben soll in diesem völlig
verfahrenen tarifkonflikt dann nur wenn
wieder neues vertrauen zwischen beiden
seiten entsteht dankeschön für diese
einschätzung aus frankfurt peter wagner
war das seit monaten schwelt der
konflikt zwischen den tarifparteien
hintergründe zum beispiel warum bislang
keine einigung erzielt wurde zwischen
ufo und der lufthansa erfahren sie auf
heute.de nach israel ungeachtet aller
korruptionsaffären bleibt
ministerpräsident netanjahu vorsitzender
seiner regierungspartei likud damit wird
er auch spitzenkandidat für die
parlamentswahlen im märz
netanjahu versprach seiner partei
einen großen sieg zum dritten mal
innerhalb eines jahres müssen die
israelis abstimmen
zuvor war der versuch einer
regierungsbildung gescheitert keiner
partei gelang es die stimmen mehrheit in
der knesset zu erreichen
deutschland gehört zu den größten
waffenexporteure der welt ein geschäft
umstritten wie kaum ein anderes
kein wunder dass diese zahl jetzt für
aufsehen sorgt die bundesregierung hat
im laufenden jahr rüstungsexporte in
höhe von fast 8 milliarden euro
genehmigt ein deutliches plus nach
jahren des rückgangs
kritiker fordern keine rüstungsgüter
mehr in krisenregionen zu liefern
nicole diekmann berichtet seit über vier
jahren herrscht krieg im jemen entführt
unter anderem ägypten und damit ein
staat der platz zwei belegt in der liste
der deutschen rüstungsexporte in
drittländer
das sind diejenigen die weder nato noch
eu angehören
insgesamt haben die deutschen
rüstungsexporte wieder den höchstwert
von 2015 erreicht die linkspartei
entsetzt die zahlen lägen ganz offen
dass diese bundesregierung hemmungslos
ja skrupellos einfach waffen in alle
welt liefert und ist sie auch nicht was
mit diesen waffen passiert
das wirtschaftsministerium verweist in
einer antwort auf eine schriftliche
anfrage darauf dass die summe der
genehmigungs werte eines
berichtszeitraums allein kein tauglicher
gradmesser für eine bestimmte
rüstungsexportpolitik sei und weiter die
bundesregierung verfolgt eine
restriktive und verantwortungsvolle
rüstungsexportpolitik vor der kamera
äußert sich das ministerium heute nicht
die grünen widersprechen und fordern ein
umdenken
es wäre ein großer erster schritt wenn
die bundesregierung die eigenen
rüstungsexportrichtlinien ernst nehmen
würde und nicht in krisenregionen
liefern würde
und es ist selbstverständlich so dass
man nicht mal ein staaten liefern sollte
die am jemen krieg beteiligt sind die
das ärmste land der arabischen welt in
die steinzeit bomben und das seit über
vier jahren
dass das immer weiter geht es schlicht
massives versagen und eine
bankrotterklärung vor allem der spd
auch die spd sagt dazu heute nichts
ein ende des krieges im jemen ist nicht
in sicht und das der debatte in
deutschland auch nicht
ein alarmierendes bild zeigt das
aktuelle krankenhaus barometer des
deutschen krankenhaus instituts danach
hat sich der personal man mit dramatisch
verschärft
vier von fünf kliniken haben derzeit
probleme pfleger und krankenschwestern
zu finden insgesamt fehlen 17.000
fachkräfte vielerorts können
dienstleistungen nicht mehr angeboten
werden
zudem suchen drei viertel der
krankenhäuser auch ärzte petra otto hat
die details eigentlich liebt ja nie
jacobi dies sein beruf seit 20 jahren
ist der pflege durch sein
überstundenkonto wächst und wächst und
kollegen hat er immer weniger im laufe
der zeit ist die arbeit mehr geworden
die bürokratie hat deutlich zugenommen
und wir haben mittlerweile stellen weise
sehr wenig zeit für unsere patienten
also würden uns schon gerne mehr zeit
nehmen aber dies einfach nicht da die
bürokratie raubt viel zeit auf zu viel
eine million stunden pro tag sitzen
deutschlands pflegekräfte am computer
schreiben statt zu behandeln und das bei
dramatischen personalengpässen das
krankenhaus barometer heute
veröffentlicht zeichnet eine
beunruhigende situation ein drittel
aller krankenhäuser musste seine
intensivstationen zeitweise abmelden
konnte bestimmte kapazitäten nicht mehr
belegen das heißt auch der rettungswagen
musste dann längere wege in anspruch
nehmen
auch im stuttgarter marienhospital
können einige intensivbetten nicht
genutzt werden händeringend suchen sie
hier ärzte und pflegekräfte noch mehr
stellen für die geld da ist aber keine
bewerberinnen und bewerber und auch kaum
nachwuchs in sicht
wir müssen mehr mitarbeiter in die
ausbildung kriegen zur gesundheits und
krankenpflege und die rahmenbedingungen
müssen verbessert werden um mitarbeiter
im beruf zu halten ist es heutzutage so
dass viele mitarbeiter nach wenigen
jahren im beruf den beruf verlassen und
sich anders orientieren pflege wohl für
viele unattraktiv vor allem wegen der
arbeitszeiten meint jan jacobi dessert
muss auch an weihnachten ran und heute
zwischen den jahren
dramatische szenen in kasachstan dort
ist ein flugzeug in ein gebäude gerast
die maschine der fluggesellschaft beck
er hatte kurz nach dem start in almaty
an höhe verloren
dann prallte sie in ein leerstehendes
haus in einem wohngebiet
an bord waren 98 menschen mindestens
zwölf starben
für begab berichtet die rettungsarbeiten
waren noch nicht abgeschlossen da nahm
der flughafen von alberti den betrieb
wieder auf dort war die fokker 100 der
fluggesellschaft lag er um kurz nach
sieben uhr morgens gestartet bei minus
neun grad und leichtem wind fast 100
menschen waren an bord
ihr ziel die kasachische hauptstadt
moseltal schon beim start treten
probleme auf
wir haben heute zwei spuren vom heck des
flugzeugs auf der startbahn gefunden
im abstand von 300 bis 400 metern das
heißt die maschine hat die stadtbahn
zwei mal berührt überlebende berichten
von einem lauten knall und das die
maschine plötzlich nach rechts abgesagt
sei dass über 20 jahre alte flugzeug
durchbricht eine beton barriere des
flughafens und stürzt in eine nahe
gelegene siedlung sofort hätten sie
verletzte aus den trümmern gezogen
berichtet ein passagier immer in der
sorge dass wack können feuer fangen mehr
als 60 menschen haben den absturz
überlebt einige von ihnen sind schwer
verletzt die kasachische
fluggesellschaft beck er ist auf
inlandsflüge spezialisiert ihre anderen
fokker maschinen bleiben am boden bis
die absturzursache geklärt ist
deutsche tschechien ungarn und viele
mehr konnten in diesem jahr das jubiläum
einer friedlichen gewaltfreien
revolution feiern die rumänen nicht zwar
haben auch sie ihre revolution im
dezember 1989 gedacht aber dort waren es
blutige weihnachtstage straßenkämpfe
hinrichtungen gewalt über 1000 tote hat
der kampf gegen das george s go regime
gefordert
und der weg von der diktatur zur
demokratie blieb auch danach ständig
britta hilpert florin kathan sq
wahlweise in diesem ehemaligen heim als
nikolai tautz esco gestürzt wurde
der diktator der unmenschliche zustände
in rumänischen waisenhäusern zuließ wenn
ich bei der mittagsruhe nicht gleich
einschlief hat man mich geschlagen
schläge konnte ich nur vermeiden wenn
ich den helfern mein essen gab ende 89
gingen diese bilder um die welt
zehntausende kinder ungewollt hungrig
krank in rumänischen waisenhäusern der
diktator nicolae ceaucescu wollte mit
dem verbot von geburtenkontrolle sein
volk und seine macht vergrößern
sein größenwahn ging auf kosten der
versorgung der bevölkerung und so
explodierte der unmut vor 30 jahren in
der blutigsten der 89er revolution über
1000 tote und das ehepaar georgias
standrechtlich erschossen
nach der revolution kamen freiwillige
aus amerika und großbritannien es kam
eine menge hilfe aus dem ausland
auch heute sind spenden wichtig für
dieses private heim zum beispiel florin
hilft hier erwachsenen weisen beim
übergang ins unabhängige leben
staatliche heime werfen sie mit 18 raus
viele betreuer seien vom alten schlag
erzählt florian die waisenhäuser sind
heute moderne aber ihr personal ist oft
in dem george s ko system ausgebildet
hat oft noch diese mentalität
sie kennen keinen hunger mehr und haben
viel mehr freiheit doch florin und die
anderen weisen meinen die diktatur sei
noch nicht vollständig aufgearbeitet
nach dem taifun auf den philippinen sind
mindestens 28 menschen ums leben
gekommen einige werden noch vermisst
der sturm hatte an weihnachten mit
windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 200
kilometer pro stunde auf der insel
getötet zahlreiche häuser sind zerstört
stromleitungen gekappt zehntausende
einwohner mussten sich in sicherheit
bringen
ganz anderes thema jetzt wer waren die
gewinner und verlierer dieses jahres im
tierreich
das hat der umweltverband wwf heute
aufgelistet ein gewinner ist demnach der
cdu hemker wasserfrosch weil sich dann
doch noch ein weibchen seiner art
gefunden hat abgesehen davon ist die
liste vor allem beklemmend der wwf wwf
spricht vom größten artensterben seit
verschwinden der dinosaurier thomas
konsum berichtet ein patient oft toten
in einem krankenhaus der kleine
dehydriert verletzt gerettet aus den
flammen in australien 2000 seiner
artgenossen sind seit oktober verbrannt
buschfeuer aber auch rodungen deswegen
sind koalas besonders gefährdet sagt der
wwf ebenso eisbären sie leiden unter der
erderwärmung laut der umweltstiftung
könnte ein drittel bis 2050 verschwinden
dickes fell auf immer dünnerem eis
auch dieser stolze jähriger stirbt der
jaguar tausende raubkatzen flohen aus
ihren revieren im regenwald vor dem
feuer oft werden sie dann erschossen
2009/10 kein gutes jahr für die fauna
auch die weltnaturschutzunion iucn
schlägt alarm
aktuell sind 30.000 arten bedroht 6400
davon vom aussterben
schuld daran vor allem der mensch
lebensraumzerstörung immer mehr plastik
in der natur wilderei und die klimakrise
das sind die entscheidenden faktoren die
dazu führen dass es auf der erde eben
den tieren und pflanzen immer schlechter
geht und den menschen denn sehen sie der
zerstörung tatenlos zu hat das folgen zb
gestoppt wird dich an einen insekten
ebenfalls ausstirbt und so wird
möglicherweise eine kettenreaktion
hervorgerufen die derzeit überhaupt noch
nicht absehbar
einzige chance sein umdenken in myanmar
klappt das da wurden elefanten gewildert
ranger schützen sie nun und deren
bestand alle jahre wieder nach
weihnachten das gleiche spiel in den
innenstädten drängen sich menschen um
die geschenke loszuwerden die gerade
erst gekauft wurden oliver dabei
hannover innenstadt das weihnachtsfest
gelaufen die besinnlichen tage vorbei
die geschäfte sind wieder geöffnet die
ersten kunden unterwegs und aus
fast nicht kommt mama und papa habe
etwas umgetauscht
warum das das portemonnaie nicht richtig
gepasst hat da passt nicht alle karten
ich habe von meiner frau zu weihnachten
einen wunderschönen fotos bekommen aber
durch die weihnachtsgans ist ein
bisschen hat ein bisschen eng gesessen
die falsche größe gekauft der duft
gefällt nicht oder einfach nicht das
passende geschenk gefunden also
umtauschen aber achtung wichtig ist
vorweg zu sagen dass es kein
gesetzliches recht auf umtausch gibt das
ist immer ein freiwilliges
entgegenkommen der händler solange die
ware mangelfrei ist anders wenn online
bestellt wurde hier gilt ein generelles
14-tägiges rückgaberecht doch in der
regel zeigt sich auch der einzelhandel
sehr kulant zu mal immer weniger
geschenke umgetauscht werden
wir schätzen eines ungefähr fünf prozent
aller geschenke umgetauscht werden dass
es relativ wenig und zwar deshalb weil
in letzter zeit immer mehr gutscheine
verschenkt werden
das minimiert das risiko für den
schenker und auch für den beschenkten
gutscheine im wert von rund 3 milliarden
euro lagen in deutschland dieses jahr
unter den weihnachtsbäumen chats der
handel aber eben auch viele sachen die
nicht so gut ankamen da könnte das eine
alternative sein
einfach die geschenke dem weihnachtsmann
direkt zurückgeben wie hier in celle bei
dieser alljährlichen aktion für santa
clause eine zweite chance menschen
glücklich zu machen
damit sind wir beim sport norbert und
einer frau die eine der letzten
männerdomänen auf mich allerdings fehlen
shahrukh 25 jahre jung frisörin
alleinerziehende mutter und der absolute
liebling des publikums bei der darts wm
in london als erste frau überhaupt hat
sie dort einen mann besiegt schaffte es
bis in runde drei heute aber das aus
gegen ihren britischen landsmann chris
tobi sie ist und bleibt die queen of
darts fällen sherlock ein starker
auftritt heutige crystal bay
gleich in den ersten 26 gelingen ihr
drei mal die 180 punkte also dreimal
trifft sie in die triple 20 anerkennung
nicht nur vom gegner fällen sherlock
geht mit 1 0 nach sätzen in führung und
kann es selbst kaum glauben
christopher
lässt nerven hadert mit sich selbst und
verfehlt immer wieder die doppel felder
cherop nutzt das aus und das publikum
tobt ich habe mich auf einer düne noch
nie so wohl gefühlt ich habe jede
sekunde genossen doch dann lässt die
konzentration der nummer zwei der damen
weltrangliste nach und das spiel kippt
christa w gelingen jetzt die
entscheidenden würfe
er gewinnt mit 4 2 nach sätzen und steht
in runde vier siegerin der herzen immer
lieb elli bleibt aber seinen sherlock
ski alpin und wieder ein top ten
ergebnis für thomas dreesen der in
bormio seine bemerkenswerte comeback
saison fortsetzt in der nachgeholten
abfahrt von gröden wurde der
mittenwalder neunter sieger auf der
anspruchsvollen piste bei schwierigen
sichtverhältnissen wurde der italiener
dominik paris ja gestern abend das
spitzenspiel in der premier league der
zweite laster gegen den ersten liverpool
am ende siegte jürgen klopps elf
souverän mit 14 0
die reds nun mit 13 punkten vorsprung
liverpool im wahrsten sinne des wortes
einsame spitze trotz der komfortablen
tabellensituation übte sich jürgen klopp
nach dem überzeugenden erfolg in
zurückhaltung
mit denken nicht darüber nach und wir
haben das auch vor dem spiel nicht
thematisiert weil es uns einfach nicht
interessiert
nach einer halben stunde erzielte
firmino im spitzenspiel gegen leicester
das 1 0
gefolgt von einer überragenden zweiten
halbzeit der ex-münchner erhöhte
unmittelbar nach seiner einwechslung auf
2 0 ehe erneut firmino traf den
schlusspunkt zum 4 2 endstand setzte
alexander arnold in der 78 minute klopp
und liverpool damit seit nunmehr 35
ligaspielen unbesiegt
einfach beeindruckend hier noch das
wetter das wochenende soll ruhig und
kalt werden zum teil auch sonnig details
hat gleich gunther tiersch christian
sievers freut sich auf sie im heute
journal um zwanzig vor elf wir danken
für ihr interesse wünschen ihnen ein
schönes wochenende und sind morgen da
wenn sie würden auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einige zuschauer die nächte werden jetzt
wieder frostig kalt luft aus nordosten
lässt es etwas den winterspüren morgen
höchsttemperaturen in mitteleuropa
teilweise nur so um die null grad
wesentlich milder ist es in westeuropa
und da wird es in den nächsten tagen
noch ein bisschen wärmer in irland und
großbritannien da kommt die luft aus
südwesten bei uns wie gesagt hier direkt
aus nordosten deshalb auch heute nach
der frost 0 bis -6 grad nur am oberrhein
bleibt es so ein bisschen gerade noch
frostfrei und dazu wird es teils wolkig
sein vor allen dingen nach osten hin da
kann es auch noch ein bisschen schneiden
am erzgebirge oder auch an den alpen
oder es klart wie im westen auch auf und
morgen haben wir dann eben auch dieses
wetter mit wolken vor allen dingen der
osthälfte sind ja etwas dichter letzte
schneeschauer vielleicht noch im
erzgebirge sonst bleibt es trocken aber
nach westen hin lockert es doch immer
wieder auf da scheint die sonne auch
zeitweise und der wind weht nur schwach
zum beispiel norddeutschland an der
nordsee hieraus süden sonst im osten aus
norden um das hoch herum ja die
temperaturen bleiben noch ein bisschen
niedriger hängen als heute das sind
minus 1 bis plus 2 grad so hier in der
osthälfte im nach westen hin sind es
drei bis sechs grad und nächsten tag
geht das ruhige wetter weiter nachts
gibt es frost tagsüber haben wir häufig
sonnenschein ich wünsche ihnen einen
schönen abend und machen sie es gut